you want to learn how to short stocks
let me tell you this the opposite of
that is called
going long buying low selling high going
long is like
going to the bar and ordering a round of
strawberry daiquiris for the boys
instead of a round of shots a whisk
going long is like getting in bed with a
girl and
asking permission for her before wow
this guy
seems nice ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the 10 million dollar studio i'm your
host
coffee zilla the internet detective
today we're talking about
arguably the worst day trader i have
ever seen and that's saying a lot i've
seen a lot of day traders talked about a
lot of them
and i don't mean that he's the worst in
terms of performance because honestly
there's always a worse day trader no
matter how bad you feel there's always
someone blowing up their account faster
than you
can okay you blow it up in five seconds
there's somebody blowing it up in three
seconds right so i don't think it's even
possible
there's a lot of big fish in the sea or
blowing up their account you know
what i'm talking about is the marketing
that this man pulls off
and recently he's been pushing an uh iq
trade
bot or something to make you rich or
something like that we're gonna talk
about that today
but my whole issue is that this is a guy
who claims to have changed
have been reformed see he used to be
excuse me a douchebag selling success
this uh
used to be him doctors typically
recommend six to eight hours of sleep at
night but money never sleeps
and neither do i
my name is cameron foose and i teach
people how to trade stock oh yeah yeah
he's
cameron foose he's a successful day
trader teaching people how to
you know how to trade stocks right so
what is this man's qualifications
besides obviously the car that's a big
qualification right there
i can't hear you for his qualifications
oh sorry he has a degree sorry excuse me
excuse me cameron did you agree
it's not mine oh okay it doesn't take a
rocket scientist to learn how to trade
stocks
as much time you spend creeping on your
ex on facebook you could be making
thousands of dollars a day
as a foos alert student guys be a
foosler student what is
foo something anyway yeah this was his
marketing before
right this was the kind of stuff he was
pulling off a douchebag selling success
as i said
but he claims to have changed and this
is the thing if you claim to have
changed you better have
changed right in a video called don't
watch this
it will change you he talks about uh you
know how
his life has gone and how he's changed
there is only one thing that truly
matters in life
one question that we all need to answer
it's not are you rich it's can you
afford the lambo have you bought it
outright or are you renting it that's
the real question
sorry maserati it's not are you
successful
it's not even are we alone in the
universe
it's one simple question that none of us
can hide from
it's are you happy
when we are young we are all naive
we all think money is the answer to our
problems
by the way you're gonna notice that like
he's like hey i know you guys are
thinking that
money is the answer to problems as he's
like flashing like a lamb or something
and
i don't know if i'm the only one but i'm
sort of getting the impression that like
wait are you flexing on us as you
describe how you've changed because this
is all about how he used to
chase fame and money and now he's above
that right he's
he's woke he's woken up as a society
we've become obsessed with what we see
portrayed in the movies and on social
media
wait isn't that you portraying it on
social media though that's that's my
point is like
you're the guy filming this commercial
by the world's top influencers
we begin to think that this made-up
fairy tale in a movie or an influencer
only displaying their best
life is what success and happiness is
supposed to look like
right that but that's you projecting
that right
this leaves us in an endless loop of
comparing ourselves to something that's
literally not even real
or attainable are you admitting that
your advertising was fake
it was it was false it was manipulative
to people who were broke out there i
don't know what
what's the point here cameron can we
have you summarize this up please
if i could tell you one thing to get out
of all this out of this entire video
it's this it's successful people aren't
happy
happy people are successful wow
that is profound you know what cameron
that's something i'd like my own
followers to
hear thank you very much sir you get the
idea
he's no longer the guy flexing he's no
longer the guy
obsessed with money he is woke
be iconic okay iconic iconic.com oh
it's a wait what are you just was this
entire thing about shilling your new
website
business pleasure bliss master classes
oh you're just
you're just selling stuff though the
whole thing about you realizing that you
don't need money
is about money and then even in the text
the description
of this woke video it's like the true
story of
cameron foose growing up at the naive
vision that if you get rich you'll be
successful
then that was the secret to happiness
okay then right underneath that
alert money face how i blew up my
brand's youtube channel by posting 1.5
times per month
resulting in 50k per month in course and
coaching sales
oh and in this more youtube videos the
true entrepreneurial lifestyle
100k in 30 days while traveling to south
africa
right yeah so you've changed though now
this is a video called
minimalism lifestyle i just moved into a
box to check my ego cool
i guess so minimalism
everybody's doing it kind of a big deal
these days maybe it's even trending on
twitter
which is why you're doing it right
problem is most of us
have our big stupid egos getting in the
way of actually doing that
like myself i've always been known for
buying big stupid things
like cars boats and going in of course
he plays the montage dude this is why
this guy's the worst
he's like yeah i used to do just like
stupid things like buying super nice
cars
buying big stupid things like cars boats
i just saved an additional 30 000 and i
did that
by getting out of all these big stupid
villas that i actually hated
and moving into a 700 per month box of
which
i'm in right now now guys again
i don't have any problem if this guy you
know maybe money's tight
maybe the cameron foose money train the
gravy train
ain't rolling from the station i don't
know what's going on with his life
you know or he's really changed right
that could have happened
let's look at what he's doing now
because the reason i'm talking about him
has nothing to do
with his minimalism his 700 box
it doesn't have to do with his video
about going and renting out pablo
escobar's penthouse
right that's the old cameron foose so
what's the new cameron fuse doing
well i checked out his most recent video
xrp
price pump and during it he starts
talking about a new
exciting opportunity for us in the
coffeezilla
army aka a trading pod guys
i always told everybody that forex
and robot trading is absolute [ __ ]
for over a decade uh until i started
using this
oh okay okay go ahead cameron okay and
that's why i
am behind this company and i am the
co-founder of iq trade
wait are you behind it or did you found
it there's a big difference i'm a big
fan of the product
also i created the the product this is
the real reason this whole video is
being made guys he's pitching
iq tray not only is he pitching it
people started linking me his stories
where he's talking about how much money
he's making
but in his link tree it says uh
automated trading forex alco
iq trade two to eight percent per
week
is gonna catch you in a coffeezilla
video every day of the week you gotta
know that cameron congratulations
you played yourself it's just
automatically trading
sitting buys and take profit targets
uh i don't i'm not doing anything so
again guys
think about this he used to say that
this was a scam uh
always right now he's selling the thing
that he said
was a scam had a 73 win rate
hitting about 3.3 return per day and now
i've upped my deposit to about 40
000 now i have 46 000 in this account
and i'm depositing another 20 000 in it
today because it's working
yeah guys it's just it's just working
that's how it works
uh now let's talk about this actual
thing right automate your forex trading
strategy today
obviously ai bots they're the buzzword
right
especially if you put them together ai
bot wow now does it mean anything
no you know a bot can be a lego
mindstorms bot
it can be a boston dynamics bot right
just like ai
can be programmed in ways that is very
good
it can also be trash on sophisticated
built on bad trading ideas
you get the picture so it's just it's a
buzz where people use to get people
thinking that oh they're gonna have some
kind of edge
but the biggest red flag is first of all
the recommended broker
that they use hey forex is it a
registered broker no
now what does this mean that they're
unregistered it means if they run off
with your money hey
too bad it's a terrible idea you should
never use
some a broker that does not fall under
some kind of financial regulation
in the country that you're living in
it's a terrible idea it's almost always
going to end badly for you
now the other major red flag is the fact
that cameron faust
foose doesn't understand math or maybe
he's just trying not to understand it
because if what he's saying is true
and that this thing is making let's just
call it two percent a week right let's
just call it two percent a week
give it conservative remember he
advertises that it's
two to eight percent per week but this
we'll just give them a bit of a doubt
we'll say two percent a week
what happens if you just stick money in
for 10 years let's say you stick 100k
in for 10 years you'd be left with a
tidy little uh
520 weeks by the way 10 years 2 billion
so so you'd be a billionaire from doing
nothing
except just sitting on your ass why
would
anyone give away such a wildly
profitable bot
obviously this does not pass even the
most basic
sniff test the reason they offer you
these insane returns is because that's
how you get people
to go with unregulated brokers right
that's how you get people to go into
risky investments is you offer them a
lot of money and people take the chance
unfortunately
but let's see if let's say we put an
eight percent right let's say that he
actually is getting the aggressive
returns that he says uh
ah yes i don't know what is that some
kind of uh
not over quadrillion dollars 10 years no
big deal
yeah so that's iq trade ladies and
gentlemen congratulations
coming to you right from mr cameron
foose himself
remember guys he's uh he's woke so he
wouldn't dare scam you
the classic get rich quick fantasy that
so many of us
naively fall victim to every day
the [ __ ] lambo lifestyle [ __ ] is so
played out and i'm so sick of seeing
it i'm gonna show you exactly how i
dropped out of college 15 years ago
bought everything i ever dreamed of
traveled the world all from learning how
to day trade joiner program this is a
forex trading robot and it's literally
pulling in about two to
five to eight percent per week i always
told everybody that forex and robot
trading is
absolute [ __ ] for over a decade uh
until i started using this i know what
you need
this ain't what it seems nothing but a
trick trying to sell me on a dream but
that was where you lost me wake up and
smell the coffee